3ポイント一番か言ったら上手くなるのー
10分ったもんでした頑張ります
はい
何がありましたね入る時3年ずっとから入ってるんですけど
入んなくなったらほんと突然乱れてリングに当たんない時とかあるんで
もうちょっと残りの5000回で精度を上げていきたいとおもいます
午前一さぁ始まりました50001回目からでございますナレーションを付けさせて
頂きますよろしくお願いします
はいもう薬価3曲ぐらいかかったねこの企画は
はいなんかね入るときは入るんですよもう5000回ぐらいから結構
連続で入る時があって車も3連続
[音楽]
青子
シュートフォームの音なんか一日に修正されて言っております
欲しい
その動きはなんだ件 suke
美味しいねぇいやーやっぱまだ波がありますねシュートに
うーんでもしっかりと日々練習していましたナイスしよう
ぴょん
ない中に連続です
エネ週3連続いいんじゃないでしょうか
ああああああ
教えでテックスを出てました
女性各地でて相当やってるでも
26本営でぃっ
[音楽]
おいね子供たちがを見てくれました緊張しました
ああああああ
ますヘルとっても可愛かったです
ああああああああ
みんなのおかげでたくさん入ったよありがとう
ファイアーで水にほどねぇ-5201いっ
サードんが打っていきましょう
[音楽]
もうこの道が長いからみんなも流すにしてていいかもー
ただ俺のシュート北で今ていく様をぜひ
バス停経験者とか見てください
着実にあのきれいになってきてるだけシュート
ん
[音楽]
2番どういってくれて助かったマジで何と日本
5301たいなければめっちゃ汗かいてだと思うんですけど ini バーにみんなで
ねシュート練習とか
商店主やなんだ結構たい事がで試合して遊んでました
はいやっぱ惜しい
試合に使えてシュートは打ちたかったんです
毎週
[音楽]
5101はい実践を織り交ぜながら電車もしてました
dai
アイスああああいうシュート気持ちいいよね宮へ入るみたいなぶーん
さあケンカしないでください
メッシュ
[音楽]
来週
ちょっとね肩のチカラがねここらへんから抜けてきてる気がするねー
なんかああ
午前500枚26パーはちょっと低いかなうん
ちょっとねぇカルビにうってでも入るとうんいいシュートフォームです
わかんないけど
シート後部良い悪いとかあるんから入ればいいんじゃないんばっ決定
そんなことをこの1万本打って思いました
moon
入るときはね香セット腕がセットの緑のわかりますでしょうか
腕がコースっと
中ってあまっすぐ向いていればもう入るみたいなところある
ねぇ4連続素
真珠
そういうこと言うと変なくなるよおっおおっ
4カード連続
ああああああ
悔しいですねぇまぁな連続帰ったらすごいよ
[音楽]
ネシア
イーヨー体の力が抜けてますねいいですよ全然
綺麗だねー自分でもなんですけど比較的綺麗だと思う
俺これなんで高校生大に連勝しなかっただろう工場からやってたら人生変わってたかな
そういうこと言うとサーんだよねそうなるんです
4月光どうしたので退け記事
お出かけてました
ありがとうございますこの体育館の音ゴールはなんかはいですか武器がするん
美しゅう
[音楽]
をないしよう
勝海舟
本当生
こんなたくさんでリバウンドに来てくれてるみんなが本当にありがたかったですよ
moon
今やるときついだからもう名札し3連続うんアイスショーツっ
ほい og 最終
ため集
さて in ジャスチャー阿蘇またいうそれ大丈夫ねそうなんかね
緊張するよね連続で入ると
美しい今いい塩浜でしたん
いいねぇチャットスッと入ると気持ちです
いいねぇ最高俺最高
変則
goo
g
だった w
41本5700米40%なかなかすごい好きを待つて
ええええええ
岩佐左山に捨てられますねー
須田は1煽るくせがありますから後輩の須田そういう男が左してあげます
[音楽]
いいねぇよねぼくすごいよ
ハイプレッシャーになりました
[音楽]
本当でこれプレッシャー直樹米連続出されると
に手動
内周
毎試合いい
ただしちゃ良い用レンズ風
tai
5連続うーん
rao
car
[音楽]
俺どんぐらいだろうグリップ結構高さっぱ気がするな
この時
いいねぇいいをこの体育館吹き
を体育館によるまで歩きもうしてきましたね
体育館とコンディションとかかなぁ結構
そうでもないん
そう川崎ブレイブサンダースさんの体育館をお借りしてね秋豚の練習もさせていただき
ました
緊張してなかなか入れなかった記憶があります
とって割烹9年体育館5分は俺達が使ってる
体育館とわけが違うけどしっかりともしっかり練習させていただきました
はぁ
やっぱ距離感がね
つがいでこの奥行きとか
あとケースキーガリ版の一人ですげーさん人だったのは覚えてますねー
[音楽]
2連続ない集
これね後ろのほうにねぇ
あの川崎ベールサンダースの関係者さんがいたんでめっちゃ
あの緊張しました
ちょっといいとこ見せようと思ったんですけど
そんな入んなかったかな気付いたらもうすぐ6戦もまだ6000この後長いからみんな
流し見していってください本当にもう俺のたわいない会話を聞きずつ
ミルってほしいから
[音楽]
が惜しい
泉北詐欺大学バスケいうと b リーグにちょっとハマっててるよく見てますねは全然
低いや200801
朝偶然800いつから5900が2回目です数え間違いです
一番回以上ってませんだから
ベア宿
5000枚技術ちょっとねやっぱ調子ばいいとゲット処理ですねそうなんですそれは
でしょ
30ちょっと戻った6cm
いやー懐かしいレモ
それじゃ
[音楽]
ただしお隣でなんかやってたら部活緊張しますねやっぱしていると思う
練習3連続
radio 4連続
[音楽]
あのシーン
いやー
me
29かちょっと下がったかな6,100はいはいもう裸にゼッケン1
6101ですない方見て危険頑張りましょう
[音楽]
危ないん
何も見えなくなりましたありがとうございました
いやー企画たねほんとにごとき曲
しくもうダメじゃなければ者ケルン
そうだね
産地めこ
[音楽]
ああああああ
気がしました
[音楽]
エラーなぁやっぱね20歩100歩つ20とか行くとさあ結構萎えるよねあちょっと
ありました25
6201分
これ雨だけで3つ床が滑って危なかったです
そういう環境もあるという
名代
メッシュ伊予床キュッキュッ聞こえるのはわかります
ラッシュは不なくても俺これやめようかと思ったけどやる時間なくてねもうこの日5分
しかなかった
これもにー回目がよく見たら6201
地区
6 a 301頑張っていきましょう足場が悪いながーい
来週は22
メシア
弊社3社に1社車
立っシェア8連続は話し合う
いいねこんな状況でこれに向かってるよ
星へ
[音楽]
外湯稼げるからいい
あっはっは
いやほんと危なかったんですよ彼の兄マジでちっけかなぁ
人が来ません
1女
あっを滑るんだよなぁ
まあでもまあが入ってるね6401もし頑張ります住んでるけど
[音楽]
30分の近所する
極刑でねパワーあふれるん
[音楽]
家でもよく入るの
ん
いや足場が悪いのがよく入ったと思いますよこの日は
あっあっ
見る分には楽しかったです
[音楽]
ないし家に連続いやもう本当に
バスケで滑るほど強いことないからねぇ
年続 a
[音楽]
疲れが抜けましたーーー
ラスターた
とリリーたら40%ですさあ
me
39パーでした6501
うーんまだこの体育館でやるか
うん
[音楽]
メッシュ連続
none
落ち着いて売ってますねゆっくりいいですよずぶのペールグッズのが一番大事ですから
[音楽]
でもこんだけなんか吸うと方が迷走してたんだよ
me
[音楽]
欲しいよ30回6000の首ちっ
逆にこれ右から打とうという作戦ですね
ナッシュいよ
左側 the 滑るから右に来たんだった気がするこれました
まあでもしっかり入れてますねどこから似合う入れれば一番よああああああを知っ
me
where
ねえ危なかった8日目体育館だして
49曲の迷宮ちゃ
ちょっとあの速受けていいですねこれはいん
34結構入りました611ちょっと待ってこのタイプかでめちぇるやん
は気がしました
さあもうせたませんですよ
[音楽]
me
落ちましたねー6,900円チップさあ体育館が変わりまたがやってだったかな
[音楽]
me
は米ナハ
いうふうにはん
ビションで停電してるからこう比べだった瞬間ぱ
てますか分かってます
ブッシュ33%なぜいちよし頑張ろうません
あと3000回です
薄いとかもちょっと変わったと思いませんかちがねぇピン体より伸びるというか早く
なったらうっていうのリリースがう
ここからちょっと調子が良くなってきた気がします
[音楽]
火を早く伸ばすことによってなんか打ちやすくなったら気がする
全然ダメだ
慣れなきゃダメなんですけどねぇ
なんかゴールの裏に当たるようになってきたい
巻貝パズルっ
路線やビーチ
うーんなんかねこの社長ば安定したけどねぇ
ゴールの裏に当たる感覚が多かったかなぁ
打ち合ったそれつとっても
打つときに腕をピンと伸ばすやつ
欲しいねぇ
いやーなんかもうちょい舟艇から玉エネルギーを止めてんじゃないかとシュート打つと
によるめっちゃ
3ポイントは中に入るじゃないですか
売った後なぁすぎててはい切り3本
このカウントにはなるんですけども
いやビジネスがいると良くないから本当は前でだけないよね
そのためちょっと腕のマンニョクとまたさんない気がする
ベッツ入れちゃうんですけど
パン2号タナ底301
31かー
なぜ親指のこれえっ
まずいろんな体育館転々としたなう
ほんと技の数とフォームはやっぱめっちゃないんでてるねー
いやーよくないよくないと思うよこんな前てるの
ちょっとストップあったり川で修正点だったかな
[音楽]
ah 番阿部の1
は宿
5点800字中瀬の手前だし殴ったてた猫ずたのでちょっとはまあやるべきで疲れた
みたいです
もうなんかインさがわからなくなってきたん
年収
30一般ちょっと戻ったならて701
どうだ来週
以上
2連続
難波配布でのリリース秋0
な一周
32いいねなぜアビーさん茶っ葉いってれば中あなたの本だと思うけど
それぞれキープしたいなと思ってやってました30一般いいねを供給7901
どんだけ体感使ったんだろう
ランする体感ちゃった方もわからんなぁ
いいねぇさあ bgm が変わったという事は沢山入る予感がしますねぇ
その
私あげるがー
ハイウェイ
あご連絡ただ的でしょ
あ
オス a
[拍手]
[音楽]
算数ごぱいいですね発生市の広毅後に旋回ですと思っていきましょう
教え
アブだ
ですねボールにごきたらちょっとじゃな顔すんだよな俺27パチョッティ下がったかな
安全約1までも2割後半でもなかなかのほうだと思いますよ
me
お決まりのアレみたいなって他の板が部屋です
汗201ね二日酔いで対処が悪いですがんばりまーす二日酔いの日も前の日にお酒飲ん
だ日も頑張りました
星
いや引く
バッチバチ二日酔い安全知浩
やっぱで太一を終わりますねするポイント体育館と
[音楽]
ブーバパティぞ
goo
3年
ダーダブーバーし
ていた
いいえ内緒
レジャー4 a
ええええええ
おっ a
たあああカーンと多くティディバンド2人しか来てくれなかっぱ do do たり
顔色悪くアフターヌーンチョンドゥ
発生のねさあこの日だけ画質がいいですあの綺麗なカメラ使いました
うわ低いなぁぞ書類
8801数と犯罪といえば t show 下がるよねー
2連続来襲
アイシェア3連続あ
登れああ夜ずゲー
[音楽]
いいねぇこれシュートフォームうできるですね最後ピント
欲しい
ええええええ
うん水平
[音楽]
いいいいい
[拍手]
来週
教えて
よしよしよしのんある近いぞ8000系[ __ ]
いいんじゃに混ぜはいいすごい良かった気がするぞマシューくん
食べたんだ800円
中 j 1層と旋回ですもうここからは全部サーバに超えたよね
朝食に一種二種4人にポンっ
両ずにはすごいよこれけっこう
wh
メッシュパンツ6はお客許可ぴよ偶然201
その感じでもう最後でこう爪
[音楽]
だいぶで前に出る勢いはでよくなって切っている木場する前に出てるんだけど
ただねほんとなんか安定するようになってきましたね
あああ4連と来たーー
まあパーセンテージレフでここまで来ると
[音楽]
nar 半月くらいそれ
22年
ナイスシュート美しいです
ライブ内野店で切り返してシュートフォームが変わってくるんですよ
もう探り探りやってますねほんといかに打ちやすく
秋冬柄ん
日々その言葉に考えておりました
いやー高校盛大にやってけるだった7連続よ
[音楽]
欲しいねぇ
34ば ok も3割0.4ひかりちゃんもっと言えば全然 ok です
カラー登り600回
[音楽]
父さんは両家強くタイタン
q 10ウェッジさあどうも厄介ですもう終盤です
もう終わること正しいくらい痛かったいいね35ば90系ビジ
wh
ラッシュ遠いよー
いいねぇ
じゃあもうほんとねぇ俺も付き合ってくれたこの皆に混ぜて感謝です
みんながいたからこそ本当にあの
すぐ追われたリバウンドとかも含め本当に有難うございます感謝しかないです
35バーン
抽選な101後300回で終わりです頑張ります
さあもうよ
最後ですここからは口数少なくいきますね
偶然ハピびちっ
[音楽]
従前901これでラストです
400やったら一番階ですちょっとなんかやっぱりゴールによってだいぶ
変動するよあと俺のコンディションとかそれも踏まえてちょっとホント難しい企画だっ
たこれ最後に言いますができます
[音楽]
ずっとへ
ています
dad
[音楽]
ん
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
惨事となった
me
[音楽]
ええええええ
goo
yeah
me
[拍手]
まあの巻分の1以上減っていますいやーん
はいと上で一番分打ち終わったんですけども10泊で入るぐらいまで来ていると思うん
ですけども
あとは本番に入るかどうかということでなぁ方連続日本に入れるからため死んだよこれ
が一番神戸結果でございます
[音楽]
の
って
me
はいっ
w
[音楽]
ん
me
[音楽]
を
おん
7ん
さーああああっ
あっはーるへ行っは